Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Reinforcement learning is a technique in the
field of machine learning to learn how to
navigate in a labyrinth, play a video game,
or to teach a digital creature to walk. Usually,
we are interested in a series of actions that
are in some sense, optimal in a given environment.
Despite the fact that many enormous tomes
exist to discuss the mathematical details,
the intuition behind the algorithm itself
is incredibly simple. Choose an action, and
if you get rewarded for it, keep doing it.
If the rewards are not coming, try something
else. The reward can be, for instance, our
score in a computer game or how far our digital
creature could walk.
It is usually quite difficult to learn things
where the reward comes long after our action
because we don't know when exactly the point
was when we did something well. This is one
of the reasons why Google DeepMind will try
to conquer strategy games in the future, because
this is a genre where good plays usually include
long-term planning that reinforcement learning
techniques don't really excel at. By the way,
this just in: they the have just published
an excellent paper on including curiosity
in this equation in a way that helps long
term planning remarkably.
As more techniques pop up in this direction,
it is getting abundantly clear that we need
a framework where they can undergo stringent
testing. This means that the amount of collected
rewards and scores should be computed the
same way, and in the same physical framework.
OpenAI is a non-profit company boasting an
impressive roster of top-tier researchers
who embarked on the quest to develop open
and ethical artificial intelligence techniques.
We've had a previous episode on this when
the company was freshly founded, and as you
might have guessed, the link is available
in the description box.
They have recently published their first major
project that goes by the name Gym. Gym is
a unified framework that puts reinforcement
learning techniques on an equal footing. Anyone
can submit their solutions which are run on
the same problems, and as a nice bit of gamification,
leaderboards are established to see which
technique emerges victorious. These environments
range from a variety of computer games to
different balancing tasks. Some simpler reference
solutions are also provided for many of them
as a starting point. This place is like Disneyworld
for someone who is excited about the the field
of reinforcement learning.
With more and more techniques, the subfield
gets more saturated, it gets more and more
difficult to be the first at something. That's
a great challenge for researchers. From a
consumer point of view, this means that better
techniques will pop up day by day. And, as
I like to say quite often, we have really
exciting times ahead of us.
A quick shoutout to Experiment, a startup
to help research projects come to fruition
by crowdsourcing them.
Current experiments include really cool projects
like how we could implement better anti-doping
policies for professional sports, or to show
on a computer screen how our visual imagination
works.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!